all right what up guys welcome to the
just curly things YouTube channel I want
to say something to the women out there
if we keep suing our bosses
for damn near everything oh he harassed
me this he harassed me that blah blah
blah
and I'm not saying there aren't cases of
real harassment but
most of y'all will sue your bosses for
damn near everything do you know what I
would do if I was a boss and I kept I
kept getting sued
for quote unquote harassment I would
just stop hiring women
it's too much of a risk and I can't
really blame them so honestly guys
ladies if we're going to be in the
workforce fine do it but don't complain
don't complain
about not getting hired for jobs if
we're gonna sue them over everything
that's my rant today like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
bye